mais si j'ai bien compris la question
c'est la question de l'impôt sur les
cartes de crédit
nous sommes absolument prête de le faire
c'est important pour le consommateur
nous avons au prato au canada pour les
pour les pour les familles pour les pour
les gouvernements à niveau de dette
insupportable
c'est un crève grave manas pour à
l'avenir si le niveau d'intérêt va
augmenter monsieur trudeau ou leur plan
pour mettre plus d'argent dans les
poches des gens il faut évidemment
travailler avec les banques avec tout le
monde tout s'assurer que les gens n'ont
pas un trop gros fardeau de dette mais
c'est pour ça que nous on veut mettre
plus d'argent dans les poches des
familles de la classe moyenne
parce que c'est ça dont on a besoin pour
créer la croissance économique sur le
plafonnement des taux de crédit de un
père et un plan pour plafonner les taux
des cartes de crédit chose que de toute
évidence ce truc on n'est pas prêt à
faire mais il est prêt à dépenser des
milliards de doses des générations
futures
il fait une longue l'espi pour tout le
reste il ya mastercard nous avec des
gestionnaires responsables ont un plan
crédible long terme pour les vrais
partenaires pour les villes pour les
provinces contrairement à monsieur
trudeau qui a une vision à très courte
vue qui témoigne de son ami expérience
c'est vrai que les dettes des canadiens
augmente mais les atouts des canadiens
augmente plus vite que ça et la réalité
que la taux de faillites a remis aux
familles sont un niveau bas historique
pour les questions d des cartes crédit
on travaille toujours avec les banques
avec les pme avec des consommateurs doit
avoir des règles qui sont propres pour
tout le monde
il faut maintenant tissu fonds pour
mettre un plafond aux cartes de crédit
au taux exigés mais il faut également
s'occuper du prix de l'essence à la
pompe est donné au bureau de la
concurrence les moyens d'intervenir
parce qu'on voit toujours dans les
grandes fêtes semaine le prix de
l'essence monte
or il ya un taux qui est un profit qui
se fait lors du raffinage
or c'est là qu'il faut intervenir il
faut que le bureau de la concurrence
plus par lui-même intervenir et mener
des enquêtes